heute sagen ich verdiene 40.000 euro nur
mit hübschen namen und dass ich wirklich
videos mal ja leute reihe woche lang
keine videos manche sagen ich bin
gestorben manche sagen upgrade hat sich
für ein action wie die von mir
gerechteren andere sagen ich habe mich
bei dem versuch vier goldene rolex uhren
zu kaufen komplett über schuld und bin
in den knast gegangen aber ich kann euch
sagen liebe leute ich war eine woche
lang krank manche bilder der stelle
jetzt vielleicht sagen okay das war eine
grippe oder so aber für mich als bisher
angefühlt wie die pest leute ich lag
tatsächlich die letzten drei tage
einfach nur im bett und ich würde nichts
machen aber das interessiert mich aber
[Gelächter]
heute fangen da wird heutigen video ich
werde heute auf die einnahmen von
youtube an reagieren
zwei leute wir wissen alle ob man das
gut oder schlecht findet geld ist ein
großes thema in unserer gesellschaft und
wir wissen doch alle dass jeder youtuber
sobald der einen youtube account in
deutschland auf macht sofort millionär
ist und er ist auch alle dass ich euch
nur diesen abschnitt meines zimmers
zeige weil der rest natürlich komplett
vergoldet ist und ich da den einen oder
anderen lamborghini geparkt habe nachdem
das geklärt haben fangen jetzt andeutet
ich schaue mir videos von youtube an in
denen die über ihre einnahmen reden und
ich denke er drauf und sagt ich alles
bullshit ist oder nicht auf diese art
von videos zu kommen ist gar nicht so
schwer man geht von der zeile ein so
viel geld und dann kommt so viel geld
nicht mit youtube und ganz oben in der
liste ist ein video vom lieben revie
durch diese klicks kann man davon
ausgeht etwa 26.000 euro da sind jetzt
an der stelle wie die erste testpersonen
im heutigen video natürlich auch am
anfang den klassischen symptomen volk
wie auch alle anderen youtuber erst mal
versucht seine einnahmen klein zu reden
versucht die tatsache zu umgehen das
weil er diverse milliarden pro jahr
verdient kinder in afrika verhungern
müssen das ist ganz normal leute aber
wir schauen natürlich durch und sind wir
mal ganz
leute ich weiß nicht ob ihr das schon
mal durchgerechnet hat aber mit 26.000
euro die zwei lamborghinis die als
minimum sind als youtuber zu bezahlen +
dann noch jedes wochenende 1000 euro im
club zu lassen wie das auch pflicht ist
als youtuber in deutschland das wird
schon relativ deswegen muss ich auch an
der stelle sagen die zahl muss man
natürlich nach oben korrigieren re wie
wenn du an der stelle der meinung ist
dass seine annahmen nicht höher als die
zahl da sind sondern geringer kannst du
antwortete video kommentieren und damit
wir auch wissen dass du es wirklich bist
würde ich dich einfach bitten kurz eines
der millennium probleme zu lösen dass
das einfach nur ein unlösbares problem
der mathematik für das eine million
preisgeld ausgeschrieben das also löw
das kurzen kommentaren und dann schreibt
eine antwort dann könnt ihr auch
berücksichtigen
da kommen wir zur zweiten person auf
unserer liste und das natürlich niemand
geringeres als sein dass julia ich weiß
heute das machen viele tore aber diese
blicke auf den fairways sind immer
wieder ein genuss wenn man sich einmal
vorstellen was die leute da vielleicht
gesehen haben die sache ist in der regel
weiß man wirklich nicht ob jetzt gerade
in youtube fahrt aufnimmt oder ob er
gerade im zweiten weltkrieg ist und vor
allem der riesige bonbruck ich glaube
dass viele leute draußen denken dass die
youtuber geld scheiße
o
deswegen wollen wir unter schauen wir
also heute youtube vom renn oder zweiter
weltkrieg man weiß es nicht aber an der
stelle muss ich sagen sein und jetzt
macht ja zumindest kann er daraus da ist
übrigens auch eine der großen ausnahme
unter den youtube die meisten halten
ihre lamborghinis verdeckt ist dass wir
nicht gezeigt sein lamborghini auch lärm
bauzeichner am start kann man endlich
respektieren der star zumindest mal
ehrlich aber ich bin jetzt auch kurz mal
ehrlich leute und würde sagen also
eigentlich hatte jetzt nicht voll in
diesem video zu werden aber meinetwegen
ihr wisst ja youtuber einnahmen setzen
sich aus youtube werbung zusammen
vermarktung ganz viele sachen und ich
würde sagen dass das aktuell für
scheiben der sv nicht vielleicht gar
nicht so sehr daneben ist das könnte
schon im kommenden ich würde
wahrscheinlich sogar sagen noch mehr
ich hab mich sagen ich verdiene
ja da der zweite max liebe leute unser
nächstes versuchskaninchen in dieser
experimentellen reihe ist altana banana
ich krieg pro tag so viele product
placement angebote hätte ich davon alle
angenommen ich hätte new york 200.000
euro läuft ja schon verdient aber ich
mache das nicht und warum mache ich das
nicht weil zwei lamborghinis reichen
aber ich habe schon so viele porträts
und anfragen bekommt ihr mein herz müsst
auch mal wieder neu sein
warum zeigt jetzt sein erdboden ich hab
mir so 9 euro schuhe gemütlicher damit
nicht an den füßen ist denkmal zum punkt
ich habe zwei jahre daran nichts
verdient kann also ich hab jetzt es gibt
nicht glaubt in dem video so viel
verdiene ich mit youtube wirklich sagt
er überhaupt keine zahl gedrückt man
will doch ich bin reich durch youtube
mit genauen zahlen immer dass man es
kann hier einmal gemeinhin geschätzter
umsatz steht hier unten hier 677 dollar
ok 677 dollar
das ist eigentlich von youtuber in
seiner größe aber schon krass wenig
davon kann man soll italienischen
sportwagen gerade mal potenten im monat
wir schauen mal wie regelmäßig der video
smart letzte upload vor drei monaten
ich würde sagen bei den abonnenten wenn
er auch regelmäßig videos macht sollte
er wenn auch bisschen vermarkten
nebenbei macht
ja also im mittleren bereich land das
ich würde sagen so 300.000 euro pro
monat
okay nicht nein aber so dass 10 12 8 von
dem was er da gesagt hat sollte man
schon erreichen weil leute ihr müsst mal
nachrechnen
jede woche muss man natürlich diese 1000
euro im club bezahlen das sind vier bis
fünf wochen pro monat 5000 euro diesen
weg gut steuern zahlen youtuber sowieso
nicht aber dann bleiben noch 3000 euro
für die sportwagen und jetzt heute
machen wir weiter mit
grenzau respekt an der stelle so video
beginnt und der leiharbeit nicht lange
rum er zeigt an der stelle auf leider
nicht seinen boden und seine schuhe und
den erd- hätte ich natürlich auch eine
stelle gerne gesehen sondern wir
sprechen als video rein und der ersten
zeit von alles 370.000 pro monat 3 168
dollar das ist eigentlich ein gutes
verhältnis sollte aber wir sehen auch
video wurde im dezember 2016 hochgeladen
dezember sind die werbeeinnahmen immer
deutlich höher
dafür ist es okay dafür ist okay wobei
das stimmt an der rechnung nicht wir
verschlagen 5000 euro pro monat fürs
feiern plus 10.000 euro für sportwagen
und da stehen 370 euro einnahmen
irgendwas ich komme nicht darauf leute
aber irgendwas stimmt nicht
ja das was dieses video ich bin direkt
von der intensivstation wieder zu euch
zurück gekommen war natürlich ein
bisschen spaßiger das video an der ein
oder anderen stelle habe ich aber auch
ernsthafte fakten glaubt wer genau
darauf achtet wird ja auch finden ich
bin jetzt wieder gesundheit das kommen
wieder regelmäßig videos und ihr könnt
damit auch ich mir die eine oder andere
italienischen sportwagen selbstständiger
ist kein beiden kammern und deutet dass
das minimum in deutschland hier mal eine
aktuelle folge von was das geht ab
checken klick darauf da konnte zum video
ich kann man ja wahrscheinlich trotzdem
keinen lamborghini leisten aber